[Applaudissements]
le syndicat c'est son salut c'est le s
pour
[Musique]
brûler
on a des choses à
la section ça fait
ok avec tout ce magnifique
[Musique]
jeu
montmartre est ce que je peux juger bien
c'est juste moi j'ai pas envie qu'il
m'aime moi j'avais pas de fuser mois
mais justement je trouve qu'elle moi je
trouve que ben y'a un truc qui est bien
c'est que l'on voit il me frappait et
pas parler d'eux enfin tu vois genre je
me suis arrêté sur de la trappe ça c'est
de la trappe à une époque où par les
gens me faisais pas trop de la trappe
non plus tu vois c'est assez nouveau
donc c'était novateur déjà la voix un
peu de recul
le styliste le style difficile prédit le
style cet édifice bleus m'a bien moi je
pense que le pire c'était le maquillage
le maquillage était difficile mais à
l'époque malade je commençais c'était
j'avais pas moins les maquillages fait
attention sachez qu'elles sont
dangereuses voilà un match
comme ça avec elle va pas au fond c'est
quoi tout le temps tout le temps
[Musique]
non mais après c'était moi comme je te
dire tu as eu 6,7 passes annoncé dans le
sens où c'est admettant sortie en 2015
mais pas de jugement là on a vu ce qui
s'est passé et post 2015 machin et ça a
évolué mais si tu le prends 2015 sans
suite je leur ai je me lance travaux
directif
comme je ne sais même pas aller quand
c'est mon papa c'est quoi la trappe à
cela on n'est pas que cela mais quand
j'ai pas de gants je suis
fier de voir comment
c'est le
premier rappeur à perdre la trappe non
plus s'emballe rappeur parce que c'était
y'a même pas y'a pas y aller il ya trois
rappeuse en tout dans toute l'histoire
une fois votre choix non mais c'est vrai
nom serait voilà il ya plein de choses à
dire mais c'est le début pour le cours
de bourse dès mon premier saut après
voilà vous by la poser sur mon premier
sont esseulés meka
néolait voilà donc c'est très bon vas-y
dit-on mot de ce que tu penses avoir le
sang
voici
pas faire de
moi alors un
clipping
t'as vu ça non non moi j'ai gagné par
rapport à où deux mois par an j'ai gagné
[Applaudissements]
j'ai choisi des gens s'étaient même pas
ça
non c'est vrai mais comme j'étais pas
mal de chemin
benjani aussi
pas mal celle pour les frères oskola
13.4 essentielle à fréquence ma mère on
met tout ça
moi je ne donne pas son nom mais c'est
qu'elle est
sûre est erroné non mais
c'est désormais sa dignité son frère
aîné lui ça
j'ai trouvé moi j'aurais dit peut-être
dégaine bel arrêt
dit
[Rires]
ca c c'est je crois que c'est l'un de
mes voici l'un de mes premiers clips
youtube sinon mais promet qu'une sur
youtube sa date de quoi si je me
rappelle bien d'à peu près à 10 ans et à
10 ans quand j'étais en groupe gt en
groupe mais avant raji à connaître je
vois
c'est là où il y avait comme un vous
avez fait un court métrage je crois
qu allez vous ragez non mais ça serait
pas chaud mais envolées pop est mort
parce que sa chute a pu collaborer c'est
vrai c'est sympa parce qu'il pensait que
c'était pas où mais mais mais mais ce
qu'il a fait mais moi j'ai envie
l'époque la juste après steve bourdon
non moi j'aime bien mais après ça permet
s'échappe chaque chaque chose en son
temps tu as vu ça c'était une époque où
je me rappelle c'est un peu plus
d'artistes et moins encore la trappe et
tout et du coup on s'est contenté jusque
là qu'est ce que vous diriez aux jeunes
disent qu'à la caisse doit travailler on
vas y j'espère qu est-ce qui devra
travailler
franchement
je veux dire ça peut-être ça manque un
peu d'originalité tu vois rester un peu
dans les codes de ce qui se fait sur le
moment mais je me cherchais sur scène
jeudi après moi j'aime bien la voix du
mec tu as une bête de wever
c'est tout gagné non non c'est muscat
croix dessus
la méthode diaby à tu avais déjà de
diaba il y avait du gel
grains de café touche du sport de fou
l'église est ou ouest à l'époque on
attend maintenant 115 6 2
non c'est moi qui gagne en vrai déjà
soulevé petit
budget
joli j'avais du mal parfois y avait pas
de but
on dirait que tu étais à 33 euros de
très joyeux voilà
[Musique]